bonjour à tous merci d'être resté on a
un petit deux minutes de retard mais ça
nous empêche pas d'avoir tout un menu
aujourd'hui à notre émission alors savez
il ya deux semaines on avait parlé de la
couverture médiatique des enjeux des
réalités autochtones et l'on s'est dit
oui mais auquel mais ils ont les
journalistes autochtone pour parler de
ces enjeux de ces réalités
alors on a réuni un gros panel pour en
discuter
beaucoup de monde autour de la table on
ira même jusqu'à québec rejoindre un
autre invité
mais avant de parler de ce sujet là je
voulais juste vous dire que lundi nous
aurons une émission spéciale vous le
savez c'est nous dit on sera quoi le 3
juin donc c'est le dépôt du rapport
final de l'enquêté nationale sur les
femmes et les filles autochtones
assassinées et disparues
ça aura lieu en matinée alors à 10
heures mais déjà il y aura une cérémonie
une cérémonie de clôture et c'est ce que
nous allons vous présenter donc à partir
de 9h vous avez sur nos pages facebook
et vous pourrez donc assisté à cette
cérémonie de clôture ensuite à dix
heures les journalistes sont conviés à
découvrir ce qu'il y aura dans ce
rapport final et nous à 13h30 nous
allons faire une émission spéciale en
direct d'ottawa avec une des
commissaires y en a quatre nous aurons
la commissaire qui parlent français bien
sûr et c'est michèle audette
alors c'est à ne pas rater et en fait
l'idée derrière tout ça c'est de vous
entendre à ce sujet passé le week end
préparez vous préparez vos questions
pour michèle audette et 13h30 lundi et
avant bien sûr vous pouvez aller sur
notre page facebook pour aller écrire
vos questions sur les pages facebook
appuyé sur messenger également donc sur
messenger sur la page facebook vous
envoyez vos questions et lundi à partir
de 13h30 nous pourrons lui poser vos
questions maintenant les missions
d'aujourd'hui qui est autour de la table
beaucoup de monde isabelle picard qui
est de retour avec nous bonjour isabelle
jean françois baudet qui est à
l'institution kiuna à odanak bonjour
monsieur moderne vous êtes quoi
l'institution conseiller pédagogique
conseiller pédagogique très utile dans
notre conversation
enduit voilà également gabriel paul qui
est une journaliste autochtone qui
travaillera d'ailleurs beaucoup avec
nous au cours des prochaines semaines et
déjà aujourd'hui à des tons travail
bonjour gabriel leurs journées de ma vie
et luc simard qui est directeur qui
travaillent sur l'inclusion la diversité
ici même à radio-canada bonjour luc et
on joue humble et puis nous allons à
québec rejoindre région et quad au
régent qui n'est plus jour est venue de
plus journaliste à la socam régent à
vous avez changé de poste pour quelques
mois depuis les sahraouis depuis deux
mois je suis l'adjoint du directeur
alain bégin et puis je m'occupe des
opérations exactement et éventuellement
je pense que vous allez vous asseoir à
la au siège de 2 florent c'est ce qui
privait enverra d'ici le mois de
novembre ce qui était d'accord alors la
première question je vais vous la poser
à tous et chacun votre tour vous allez
pouvoir me répondre quelle place occupe
les autochtones en journalisme isabelle
enfin de mon constat n'y pas beaucoup de
journalistes autochtone disons dans les
grands médias bien sûr il va y en avoir
dans les communautés on donne aux radios
communautaires on ne la socam on a on ne
met magana voir guilon une télé un poste
de télé juste pour eux donc on est à ce
niveau là mais dans les grands médias on
tarde à faire ne placer quand même des
initiatives qui ont été faites entre
autres par radio canada depuis plusieurs
années pour avoir des stagiaires
autochtone mais la place est encore elle
reste afin oui alors on va expliquer
d'où vient la faute est ce qu'il y à une
faute venant de quelqu'un d'un organisme
et où il n'y a pas de faute c'est
jusqu'à personne qui est intéressé par
ce métier là c'est ce qu'on va découvrir
monsieur baudet quelle place occupe les
journalistes autochtone dans les médias
c'est une bonne question je te la
personne la mieux placée pour répondre à
cette question est ce que je peux dire
c'est que nous on a un programme
eux qui vise à former les jeunes pour
devenir journaliste ou un nouveau
programme où on essaie de mettre en
place avec la deuxième année avec la
cgem de jean guerre et on aimerait bien
formés que john stockton pour devenir
journaliste on va en parler du programme
gabriel est un mois même journal
je constate qu'on est peu dans les
grands médias effectivement mais c'est
sûr qu'au niveau local comme isabelle le
disais on sait c'est quand même assez
vivant et tout mais c'est sûr que de
niveau 1 général d'un oeil québécois ont
elles et on est peu présente
leak gérer simplement lui fasse que
certainement les autochtones n'occupe
pas la place qu'il devrait occuper et
raison je dois faire le même constat que
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de tact un journalisme là les
grands médias et puis au niveau laquelle
même nous autres dans les eaux de la
socam
il y en a pas tant que ça il ya quelques
radios qui ont des journalistes mais pas
tant que ça oui donc même dans l'est
dans les médias autochtone n'y en a pas
tant que ça non plus alors j'essaie de
faire une recension en fait les
journalistes autochtone passé et présent
présent présent présent présent on va
aller dans l'ouest du pays christiana qu
une métis du manitoba
elle est à radio canada à winnipeg si on
se rapproche au québec marie michèle
sioui correspondante parlementaire à
québec pour le quotidien le devoir
jennyfer o'bomsawin elle elle est
journaliste à tva
à québec il ya bien sûr michel gens qui
lui est journaliste ici à tva montréal
maintenant ce qui ne se font plus du
journalisme
emma saganash qui a pris sa retraite
d'il ya quelques années de cilicie il y
avait bien sûr mirent à crimolois caméra
cri très connu ici à radio canada je
pense qu'elle a fait toute sa carrière à
radio canada d'ailleurs mira cris et
puis il y avait jean paul le waouh de
l'eau hâte qu'on appelait jean paul naud
l'est d'ailleurs qui a été lui aussi un
très grand journaliste à radio canada je
sais pas si à l'époque d'ailleurs les
gens se rendaient compte que c'étaient
des autochtones est ce que eux étaient
fiers de montrer leur origine est ce que
quelqu'un se rappelle même mois pour
avoir enfin les avoir vus et entendus
quand c'était la radio et à la télé puis
l'avoir lu un peu sur ce qu'ils étaient
sur leur identité c'est ce qu'il
n'hésitait pas à mettre cette identité
en avant pas nécessairement
quotidiennement dans les productions de
radio canada mais il en était fier
tant mieux tant mieux c'est ça
exactement l'important est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on est fiers d'être une
journaliste autochtones gabriel
oui tout à fait c'est sûr que quand je
suis pas un espace autochtone quand je
fais du journalisme plutôt général c'est
pas quelque chose que je met de l'avant
nécessairement mais dès que j'ai
l'occasion de la fin c'est sûr que je le
fais jamais c'est pas quelque chose que
je cachais j'en parle à qui veut bien
l'entendre
réjean vous est ce que vous êtes fier
d'être un journaliste autochtone de
faire du journalisme autochtone et c'est
moi je suis fier et puis vous nommiez
les journalistes tantôt personnellement
il ya quelques journalistes que je ne
savais jamais je ne savais pas que
c'était des autochtones puis c'est tous
les saints donc viable fier de voir
qu'il y avait des autochtones qui lie à
des autochtones
le musée alors pourquoi il y en a pas
plus luc pourquoi il y en a pas plus
parce que vous voulez sollicités
régulièrement les jeunes autochtones
oui bien évidemment il ya un petit
bassin des autochtones qui ont le
français comme langue maternelle ou
comme deuxième ou troisième langue sont
quand même de deux nombres limités au
québec et il y à quelques médias russes
non autochtone comme la socam ou travail
région qui diffuse en langue autochtone
ce qui est vraiment fondamental donc
travail en français radio canada c'est
déjà pour plusieurs travailler dans sa
2ème ce troisième langue et sa et
l'absence de modèle
suffisant faire en sorte événement qu'on
n'est pas tellement intéressé ou enfin
automatiquement je devrais y l'intéressé
sur les autochtones devenir journaliste
et peut-être que gabriel de serait mieux
que moi mais je pense que ça ces deux
facteurs qui qui joue et il y à aussi je
dirais
peut-être parfois une idée inadéquation
pour utiliser un grand mot entre se
courront ce que des autochtones qui sont
venus chez nous on a envie de faire puis
ce qu'on leur demande de faire à radio
canada ce qui peut être un peu pour
certains d'entre eux qui ne correspond
pas à leurs désirs je parle ici de
formats par exemple on sait pour avoir
passé une bonne partie de ma vie moi
même dans cet environnement de nouvelles
que la fabrication de nouvelles c'est un
peu une chaîne de montage politique il
faut que chacun joue son rôle précis sur
la chaîne et c'est pas les services ce
qui est du goût de beaucoup de gens
gabriel parce que évidemment vous êtes
encore sur les bancs d'école donc vous
le considérez aussi bien ici si je
reprends quand j'étais plus jeune quand
j'étais au secondaire moi la
communication c'était quelque chose qui
était facile pour moi puis j'ai
l'impression que peut-être mes collègues
de classe était pas un
un environnement qui qui peut les
attirer c'était des gens plus réservé
peut-être un peu plus timide que moi je
voulais donc c'était pas du métier vers
lesquels ils étaient tentés vraiment
vous pourquoi au delà du fait que vous
étiez déjà une bonne communicatrice
pourquoi le journalisme on a un peu
poussé dans cette voie là ouais ouais
quand je suis entrée au secondaire
j'ai fait atm au cégep de jonquière mes
professeurs et comme tu devrais vraiment
aller en atm quand on est rendu au cégep
et où ils m'ont toujours poussé la dent
et quand il y avait des trucs de
communication fallait à l'école des
présentations des expo-sciences j'étais
toujours sollicité pour ces choses là
donc c'est devenu plus de 1000 parties -
oui là vous êtes cet été vous avez passé
beaucoup de temps à l'espace au top
j'ose espérer lui c'est alors est ce que
vous avez envie de faire du journalisme
pour parler aux autochtones journalisme
pour parler des autochtones à tout le
monde
c'est quoi votre vue un espace
autochtone évidemment on fait du
journalisme on parle des autochtones aux
autochtones et aux jeunes autochtones
mais vous éventuellement dans le futur
mais une des raisons qui m'a aussi
poussé vers le journalisme c'est le fait
que je constatais que la façon dont les
autochtones
étaient reportées dans les médias qui
était peut-être pas représentatif de ce
que moi je voyais dans ma communauté ou
dans d'autres communautés que je
visitais donc c'était vraiment un désir
de vouloir raconter les choses comme
elles le sont avec une vision de look à
l'intérieur pour avoir vécu dans une
communauté je pense que j'ai un regard
plus juste sur quelqu'un qui ait vécu
tout ça l'amour est allé que jamais eu
de contact avec un membre d'une première
nation ouais donc c'est j'ai envie de
parler des enjeux autochtones
oui pour les autochtones pour informer
les autres acteurs mais aussi pour la
population générale pour leur donner
leurs jeux sur les réalités convient oui
isabelle est ce que à espace autochtone
par exemple il ne devrait y avoir que
des autochtones
ah oui cette question déjà vainqueur ici
ils le font uniquement entre d'auxerre
des jeans oui absolument
maintenant est-ce qu espace autochtone
devrait avoir seulement que des
autochtones moi je suppose partage des
connaissances on l'a dit tout à l'heure
le bassin de journalistes ou de
chroniqueurs autochtone il est petit
radio canada a une expertise qu'on n'a
pas nécessairement comme autochtone donc
pourquoi pas en tout cas au départ créer
une collaboration je pense que c'est
tout à fait possible et c'est tout à
fait dans avantageux d'un côté ou de
l'autre
maintenant est ce qui devrait avoir plus
d'autochtones l'espèce autochtone
absolument on va les trouver
oui c'est l'autre question parce que
c'est un automatisme ans je me souviens
car c'était le temps de faire mon choix
pour l'université il ya 20 ans déjà des
communications et le journalisme comme
il ya pas de modèle on se retrouve pas
et souvent quand on fait les premières
pages des journaux
ben c'est pour des raisons qui sont
plutôt négatives des barricades et donc
le traitement yport est pas tout à fait
adéquats par rapport à ce qui se passe
vraiment par rapport à commençant par
rapport aux réalités oui et donc ça fait
en sorte qu'on n'a pas vraiment envie
d'aller leur hockey alors prenons un
exemple michel jean oui il est quand
même à tva il est à morale il est très
connu il est passé par radio-canada à
tva
c'est un modèle
oui c'est un modèle michel c'est un ami
donc je connais un peu son histoire mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a grandi à à son
réel
donc il n'était pas dans une communauté
comme tel les choses c'était peut-être
plus facile déjà à l'extérieur
maintenant le défi c'est vraiment
d'aller chercher des autochtones dans
les communautés seller je pense le grand
défi mais c'est sûr que michel
maintenant que ce soit à travers la
littérature donc ses romans ou à travers
son travail de journaliste
c'est devenu un modèle et les chefs
d'antenne loi quelque part oui ou
autochtone absolument donc c'en est un
mais ça fait pas très longtemps qui
s'affirme comme autochtones ont vu donc
c'est relativement nouveau également à
ce niveau alors faut aller les chercher
dans les communautés donc c'est un peu
votre rôle monsieur baudet monsieur
simard comment vous faites pour aller
les chercher parce que alors on va on va
parler des programmes il ya deux
programmes y en a chez vous et y en a
chez vous donc ateliers d'initiation
radio-canada conseil en éducation des
premières nations
je pense que c'est la troisième fois que
vous essayer d'attirer des autochtones
qui auraient envie de devenir
journaliste
ça a marché deux premières fois mais pas
cette fois ci le troisième était celle
de trop
je pense quand on fait une offre comme
celle là donc s'agissait d'une semaine
de formation à cuba pour des gens qui
n'étaient pas nécessairement décision de
cuba parce que les cours sont terminés à
cuba est un collège et il est session
collégiale sont terminés oui ou non on
constate donc c'était légende extérieur
si le plus compliqué sur le plan
logistique que je pense pour beaucoup de
gens et ils selon m aperçois c'est que
ce type d'offres n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur type actuellement ça marchait
dans les dernières années mais il faut
penser à autre chose il faut il faut
trouver d'autres façons de de rejoindre
les
les autochtones intéressé par le
journaliste mais cette fois ci ce sera
par du coaching qu'on fera distance
débat avec les participants qui
s'étaient inscrits avait quand même eu à
peu près une demi douzaine de
participants qui s'étaient inscrits
s'étaient pas suffisant pour tenir le
programme mais on va faire du coaching à
distance et on pense que ça va mener
vers d'autres types de contacts plus
rapproché avec radio-canada par dessus
mais pour apporter une nuance même si
bbc a de la difficulté et je le dis pas
pour nous vanter radio-canada ou pour
critiquer nos collègues de civisme et je
travaille avec eux mêmes espaces même à
siby cndd et de jeunesse l'équivalent
d'espèces autochtones ce n'est pas une
majorité d'autochtones qui travaillait
beaucoup de non autochtone qui
travaillent à sybille sind et je ne
laisse ceux qui sont à l'écran ou qu'il
faut il ya beaucoup d'autres comme il ya
beaucoup de jeunes autochtones puisque
enfin une sans entrer dans des détails
leur leur service et très décentralisé
donc dans plusieurs villes canadiennes
mais s'il est basée à winnipeg ce qui
n'est pas le cas d'espèces autochtones
et demain que tous ses effectifs ici à
montréal mais juste pour dire que donc
il ya un défi les chefs du canada
alors c'est ça que je veux que je veux
dire en fait c'est qu'on a tous le même
défi non seulement d'attirer des
journalistes autochtone et de les garder
et ça aussi c'est une difficulté du côté
suisse il ya
une énorme va et vient et souvent les
gens ne restent pas très longtemps
alors donc l'organisation n'est
probablement pas suffisamment
accueillante pour garder nos collègues
autochtone que nous recrutons à la socam
régent à la socam est-ce que vous gardez
les journalistes que vous recrutez mais
il ya des journalistes il ya des
employés qui sont là depuis une
vingtaine d'années plus d'une vingtaine
d'années mais il ya aussi de roulement
du roulement effectivement et puisqu'on
va coucher à la socam et puis je veux
souligner c'est peut-être les loin il
m'a aussi des débits gens hein c'est pas
tout le monde qui nécessairement prêts à
aller habiter en ville de déménager de
sa communauté donc sélectif et vous à la
soquem vous êtes donc en banlieue de
québec là vous vous êtes à luanda qui
est donc faux quand même quitté sa
communauté pour aller attaquer et puis
je rajoute quelques à-coups 9
on ouvre un pass de journalistes la
plupart du temps c'est des gens qui
vivent déjà dans la région de québec
donc il y en a pas beaucoup qui applique
ceux qui habitent dans les communautés
oui puisque la socam dessert des
communautés atikamekw les communautés
innu donc ce doit être des inouk et des
attikameks qui vivent déjà dans dans la
grande région de québec
born this way ce qui n'est pas facile du
tout enfin c'est plutôt c'est pas la rue
et maintenant on affiche un poste non
c'est qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est
ce que vous tentez de faire pour les
attirer les jeunes pour avoir de la
relève journalistique
ben un affiche à l'emploi déjà lot un
emploi en ville
comme je vous disais il ya 10 à dumont
qui sont déjà en ville et puis que les
autres sont prêts à les travailler parce
qu'il ya un emploi dans une comme notre
communauté autochtone en plus pas loin
de la ville mais ceux qui habitent en
région c
je sais pas comment comment voulez vous
le dire je ne sais pas comment les
attirer mais il mais il ya aussi le fait
que le métier en soi une journaliste
exposé au public exposées public c'est
pas tout le monde qui nécessairement
prêts à s'exposer de même
et puis on dit souvent aussi que les
autochtones sont de nature plutôt timide
alors il ya peut-être ça aussi qui est
un facteur qu'il faut qu'on y est ce qui
n'est peut-être pas évident non plus
c'est que vous vous allez voir ce qui se
passe dans vos communautés parler de ces
communautés quand c'est bon c'est
formidable quand on en parle en moins
bon c'est pas évident non plus photo
quelqu'un souligne s p craint qu on
expose les autochtones dans les médias
les grands médias c'est plutôt qu'un
c'est des affaires plus négative
oui non mais ce que je dis c'est que par
exemple vous à la socam bon bain par
exemple vous aurez gens quand vous étiez
journaliste et vous alliez dans votre
communauté vous voyez une nouvelle qui
est peut-être moins intéressante et vous
devez dévoiler des informations qui vont
qui ne vont pas plaire nécessairement à
la communauté ou conseil de bande
ça aussi c'est difficile non comme un
fouet la perfection c'est la proximité
de proximité il ya des communautés même
dans les réseaux de la socam ya des
radios locales qui vont même qu'ils sont
obligés d'aller chercher des
journalistes à yahr à cause de la
proximité parce que tout le monde vit
ensemble et puis il ya des choses et
quand vous dites qu'il faut des fois
dévoilé et puis après ça tu vois là la
personne même où la famille de sept
personnes mènent dans la communauté
parce que c'est des petites communes
louis rue en la bonne foi au quotidien
après c'est pas évident non mais vous
avez raison
trop longtemps quand on a parlé des
enjeux autochtones c'était pour parler
du négatif et je me rappelle être allé à
qui mena il ya deux ans et j'avais parlé
avec des jeunes je leur disais mais
pourquoi vous vous lancez pas en
journalisme c'est un super métier tout
pu me dis ben non ça ne m'intéresse pas
de parler des mauvaises choses mais il
n'y a pas seulement des mauvaises choses
oui mais ce qu'on entend des grands
médias tradition
elle c'est tout ce qui est mauvais et
c'est vrai qu'ils n'avaient pas tort
mais les choses ont tendance à changer
non isabelle oui mais ça y est je pense
que l'avenir va être meilleur pour la
profession de journaliste autochtone en
particulier est ce que l'un des modèles
1 on annonce des bonnes nouvelles
notamment grâce à espèces autochtones
qui laisse une grande place qui est
positif oui mais c'est vraiment le
premier point encore mais on y arrive
bon donc on a déjà fait un petit pas on
espérait qu'il va être plus grand jean
françois baudet vous avez un programme
qui est relativement récent ça fait deux
ans fait ce dec entre kim yu-na et la tn
de saguenay oui c'est la deuxième année
qu'on essaie de le mettre en place oui
de le mettre dans le fond l'idée du
programme c'est de mettre ensemble
l'expérience qui n'a que les étudiants
vivent chez nous en ce moment et les
combinaisons avec toute leur expertise
puissent installations dotées m à
jonquière donc avoir le meilleur des
deux mondes en voyant dans le fond quand
je parle d'expérience qui nous noie dans
le fond c'est ce qui nous permettra tant
parlé de comment on arrive à faire venir
les jeunes en dehors des communautés
makoun ont réussi d'une seule façon d'en
recréer une vie communautaire comme
trois dimension à l'expérience qu'ils
aient ou non il ya un des activités
culturelles qui sont vraiment des
activités par exemple le déséquilibre de
la tradionnelle on note des mêmes les
voyages par exemple cette année on de
des étudiants qui sont allés rencontrer
les meilleurs mais aux mexicains sont
allés au nouveau-mexique julie navarro
on a un groupe qui revient aujourd'hui
dans un échange à qui ça me en finlande
donc le volet culturel est important on
est sport
[Musique]
psychologique aux étudiants de ce
secteur qui canadiens devraient penser à
travers des études loi afin que leurs
différentes problématiques les appelle
les avesnois abandonné leurs études et
tout le contenu du programme qui
vraiment inconnu premières nations ce
soit par exemple dans les cours
sciences politiques histoire mais même
en administration une voix les lacs est
abordée il étudia chez nous ayons
vraiment une expérience complète comme
jeu quand j'enseignais la première
journée le premier coup j'ai toujours
utilisé elle vous ennuyer de chez vous
mais deux semaines puis dans les faits
près de zinc ne veulent pas partir donc
on a cette expérience lors qu'on est
vive et l'on voulait maintenant combinez
cela avec ce fait un journalisme pour
finalement attiré des jeunes à la fois
dans l'enseignement supérieur à la fois
pour la formation de journalisme donc je
vais pas redire annie vous en avez
attiré aucun nom n'a plus d'inscriptions
la première année là vous êtes en
période de régulièrement et comment ça
se passe on attend toujours des
inscriptions
je pense que vraiment deux aspects qu'il
faut regarder l'aspect bonne tête le ce
métier-là particulier qui perçu comme
inaccessible d'une certaine façon de
parler bhoutan à tout mais l'autre volet
qui est important c'est tout l'accès à
l'enseignement de la semapa secondaire
des jeunes des communautés un gros
problème qu'on a c'est qu'il faut
énormément de succès au secondaire dans
les communautés pour des raisons de me
source dans les écoles cela tout se voit
les lacs étaient pourtant donc si on n'a
pas de finissants de secondaire on en a
pas pour l'ensemble des métiers est un
ferment de formation postsecondaire on a
des difficultés elle je pense que c'est
pas limiter ou jallet 0 on avait une
discussion cette semaine en journée
pédagogique avec les enseignants déjà
quand on cherche déjà dans le domaine du
cinéma / déjà dans le domaine des arts
administration désert et la même
problème se trouve partout oui
justement de faire un peu de pouce ce
que jean-françois de 6,6 si c'est mon
impression mais pourrait être confirmée
ou infirmée par les collègues autour de
la terre j'ai l'impression que les
autochtones avec avec certains diplômes
diplôme collégial un diplôme
universitaire ou des études
universitaires sont très sollicités en
ce moment pour toutes sortes par toutes
sortes d'organisations pour toutes
sortes d'emplois
donc pour revenir à l'expérience qui n'a
pas fonctionné d'organiser une semaine
de formation à cul là on n'est pas
rémunéré pour y participer
on n'est pas que les 10 t on reçoit pas
de crédit collégiale pour pour des cours
donc c'est peut-être finalement
peut-être possible intéressant que ça
pour des gens qui ont d'autres occasions
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
j'ai envie de parler un peu de soi parce
qu'en fait je pense que les autochtones
vont beaucoup j'ai travaillé longtemps
au conseil en éducation des premières
nations puis ils vont aller voir les
besoins urgents quand ils vont faire
leur choix au niveau secondaire
c'est-à-dire travail social y en a plein
infirmerie t pour être infirmier en
dessous des gages en éducation
donc tout ce qui est vraiment en
sciences politiques en anthropologie à
l'université ça c'est des choses qu'on
voit de plus en plus mais le journalisme
dans la liste de ce qui est urgent parce
qu'on veut aider nos communautés ont
volé les choses est normal va arriver
10e le temps bowling jusque pas de
modèle oui mais en plus ces métiers là
c'est une façon aussi ses professions de
rester dans sa communauté au 16e doit
être obligé de quitter la ligne à une
autre
gabriel est ce que le métier de
journalisme est un métier inaccessible
on parlait d'inaccessibilité de plus en
plus je crois que ça devient que c'est
pour les autochtones
en fait j il ya quelques années j'aurais
jamais cru que je serai ici à radio
canada a à être journaliste et je suis
encore assez jeune donc je crois qu'il
ya une volonté
des médias de nous écrire de plus en
plus donc ça devient de plus en plus
accessible dans dans les communautés il
ya des radios communautaires donc il ya
déjà des jeunes ya des moins jeunes qui
font de la radio est ce qu'il ya des
télévisions n'ont pas nécessairement à
ce qu'un soin du web
magana wadia c'est vrai c'est la seule
est ce qu'il ya des journaux aussi il ya
des petits journaux
donc il ya des journalistes là derrière
alors pour vous par exemple acquis ona
ou à radio canada on peut pas aller dans
les communautés à l'échauffement on veut
pas évidemment les déloger enfin les
intentions déshabiller paul pour
habiller région faisait allusion tout à
l'heure à la discuter aussi de faire du
journalisme dans un petit milieu alors
que je suis autonome unit automne je
viens d'une région moi même le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean c'est plus
difficile de faire un journal dit on
d'un quartier de montréal mmm est de
voir justement rencontré des commerçants
chaque jour sur lesquels on vient
d'écrire un article ou de qui on vient
de deux dames d'une critique alors c'est
séditieux le faire du journalisme local
c'est très très difficile et je pense
qu'on le vit en milieu autochtone comme
on le vit en milieu non autochtone et
c'est donc une dimension particulière
sortir les gens des communautés d
emmener vers un autre dans la grande
boîte de montréal par exemple c'est
autre chose ça demande de ceux de se
déraciner de déménager de se réinstaller
des puits les coûts du logement en ligne
de compte et se verra alors si c'est des
facteurs kellou qui nous est pas puis le
recrutement au catch fallu ions dans les
communautés locales peuvent vraiment
possible la tension est trop trop grand
il faut il faut des étapes
intermédiaires avant de partir d'un
petit journal local qu'ils soient
autochtones une odeur et dans l'arrivée
dans une grosse salle de nouvelles comme
celle de montréal ou même de travail
espace autochtones parce que vous êtes
fondamentalement vous êtes
fondamentalement dans la grande salle de
nouvelles de montréal oui
j'ajouterai aussi que dans les petits
dia locaux dans les communautés
généralement les gens qui font un
travail journalistique n'ont pas de
formation de journalisme donc ils font
un travail journalistique mais sans
avoir eu de formation que je dois au
cégep ou à l'université donc ça aussi
pour aller ailleurs c'est possible oui
réel
oui peut-être que dans la dans le
programme journalisme ki moon on prévoit
adaptées aussi l'allaitement sont plus
techniques du travail de journalisme à
l'ariel dd com ou des loges demain ce
qu'on parlait la proximité l'importance
de crédit de la confiance avec les gens
ça où ce serait un atout dans là ça va
se traduire comment ça concrètement en
trottant nayar courageux demain des gens
qui ont l'expérience du jour 17 octobre
soirée niçois venir dans les courants
par des régents à la socam est-ce que
vous embauchez des journalistes formés
en journalisme je sais qu'il ya eu il ya
de la collaboration aussi avec radio
canada avait plus qu même et sinon quand
vous allez dans les communautés est ce
que vous allez chercher des gens qui
font de la radio communautaire par
exemple mais qui n'ont pas
nécessairement une expérience et les
diplômes associé à ma connaissance et la
plupart je pense des journalistes qui
ont travaillé la socam qui travaillent
présentement ils ont pas nécessairement
deux formations n'ont pas de diplômes
dans le domaine et ont des formations
dans d'autres domaines
et puis c'est c'est beaucoup par
l'apprentissage de ceux qui sont déjà là
depuis déjà quelques années
et puis évolué mentionniez on a des
formations aussi en trop dans les
canadiens au canada les formations
ponctuelles donc
il n'y a pas beaucoup de journalistes
autochtone qui ont des diplômes donc
c'est difficile d'aller trouver à radio
canada il ya espace autochtone en
français il ya 6 bis idée de génie et il
ya 6 bis in north qui diffuse en cris
est ce que radio canada devrait ouvrir
son offre est diffusé en innu par
exemple si tu me pose la question du we
may b en même temps john non plus moi je
pense qu' il fallait pas déshabiller un
réseau comme celui de la socam la poche
que je privilégierai mois sur l'a20 si
on avait les moyens de faire ce que tu
réfléchis on a droit de rêver d'accord
mais ce serait de travailler avec la
socan pour voir comment est ce qu'on
peut faire des choses ensemble et
renforcer se renforcer mutuellement de
cette manière là pour pas dédoubler
réseau canada va toujours à vraiment
d'autre est très large de faire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses et on pourrait
ajouter un volet de langue autochtone je
le désirais mois les mais je pense que
ce serait vraiment important de
travailler avec les médias autochtone
qui existent on faisait ça oui mais en
même temps l'idée n'est pas non plus de
ghettoïser non plus parce que d autres
jeunes qui parlent encore en hauteur à
l'heure à leurs concitoyens dans leur
langue
l'idée aussi c'est que des autochtones
puissent s'exprimer à travers le pays
mathon en français ou en anglais et donc
qu'on entende leur voix avec les non
autochtones entendre leur voix
et ça c'est ce qui manque oui c'est ce
qui manque effectivement puis le côté
ghettoïser ça me fait toujours un peu
rire est ok très péjoratif et selon moi
d'avoir des autochtones qui racontent
leur histoire ce n'est pas de gaieté
risée c'est au contraire c'est du rien
sans nous sans douche une grande fan
voiture j'en parle c'est très long mais
c'est justement c'est c'est de pouvoir
raconter avec notre vision des choses
notre réalité notre rythme aussi on
parlait de rythme tout à l'heure d'une
manière qui peut être un peu différent
mais qui vaut à aider ou c'est raconter
l'histoire
va aider à faire comprendre à
sensibiliser les gens et c'est ça qui
manque
je pense beaucoup beaucoup au pays alors
les solutions là il faut les trouver
on a quelques minutes pour trouver la
fusion qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu est-ce qu
on devrait changer
comment on devrait changer les choses
ses positions si on devait amener des
solutions lan fait un brain storming qui
ont dit ok qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire
pour attirer les jeunes autochtones dans
cette profession là c est vraiment une
excellente question je vous aime
beaucoup de gens qui réfléchissent à
seuil qui essaie de trouver une solution
à ce moi je leur dirai juste que c'est
vraiment les excès un bon métier devrait
pas hésiter à devenir journaliste quand
on a besoin d'eux parce que on est
vraiment sur représentés on a besoin
d'entendre les des voies diverses dans
nos maisons
c'est sûr si je peux me permettre à
désirer sans moi je crois que la
solution est en train de la vie le fait
que la vie au canada recherche des
autochtones est ce qu'il faut surtout
pas je pense et d'abandonner de baisser
les bras
je pense qu'il faut continuer dans ce
sens là parce que l'étudiant vous ne
vous en parliez tantôt l'étudiant qui
doit faire un choix de carrière
ce n'est pas nécessairement le métier de
journaliste qui l'a t-il parce qu'il ya
peu d'offres d'emploi pour les autres
dans les communautés humaines dans les
grands médias
même si c'est ouvert à tous évidemment
mais il ne voyait pas là dedans donc il
faut il faut continuer je pense les
efforts dans ce sens le puy on est en
train de livrer radio canada est en
train de les faire rentrer mais je puis
dire moi je suis devenu jeunesse parce
qu'il ya des gens qui m'ont encouragé à
le faire donc c'est vraiment c'est une
question de cercle et de collectivités
si quelqu'un le potentiel cessé de le
pousser à aller vers ce mois ci ou comme
ça que je suis ici aujourd'hui parce
qu'ici on révèle à qui on avait promis
plus de moyens moi je veux pour aller
dans un sens que vous deux
il faut aller voir les jeunes il faut il
faut aller visiter les écoles il faut
aller dans les communautés mais aussi en
ville puisque la moitié des autochtones
vie en ville
il faut trouver une façon de rejoindre
les autochtones en milieu urbain
également pour leur part les deux
métiers possibles dans les médias dont
le métier de journaliste mais qui n'est
qu'un des dizaines de métiers qu'on a
ici parce que le réseau au canada il ya
des des techniciennes nos collègues qui
sont derrière la vitre les gens ne
voient pas mais oui ils sont importants
dans le fonctionnement de 2,2 tout ce
qu'on fait il ya des gens en financer
des gens avec ce que de revenus à des
dons que toutes sortes de 2006 ici et
ici c'est nous la dire aux jeunes qui
sont intéressés n'a pas hésité à
s'inscrire le la place et on n'a pas un
jour n'est cependant pas aussi
productions radiophoniques pour
s'adapter à l'ariel d'aider des
communautés où ils sont tous des radios
alors que ceux qui hésitent pas à
s'inscrire on les atteint puis je sais
aussi qu'à radio-canada
il ya des visites organisées scolaire
j'ai une amie qui viennent montmagny qui
fait une visite une fois par année avec
un zoom en r3 éviter des autochtones ils
vont voir que c'est possible
c'est un peu comme un étranger c c et
lienz et rorato canada c'est trop gros
oui je pourrais jamais et là il ya un
peu je m'amusais c'est la même chose le
18 mai mais a justement en faisant
visiter des gens des communautés je
pense que à radio-canada ça va un peu
démystifier tout ça puis ça va peut-être
justement les intéresser à des métiers
de la radio la télé du web donc ça peut
être intéressant aussi au niveau des
critères d'embauché
je sais pas où ça en est mais comme
monsieur
le disais tout à l'heure on n'a pas
nécessairement de baccalauréat en
communication en journalisme donc
peut-être ben permettre le fait que will
autochtone voit quand même une formation
attaque quand un cas autochtone c'est un
peu drôle à 2020 il connaît ses réalités
connaissez en jeu il y aura un réseau
qui va énormément aidé et il s'agit à ce
moment là de créer une collaboration
entre toutes les expertises que vous
avez ici à radio canada est la personne
qu'il est je pense pour que ça puisse
être gagnant oui il ya un autre grand
média dont on n'a pas parlé ces épis
tienne avant john hall public d'origine
network qui va commencer d'ailleurs à la
fin d'été un bulletin de nouvelles en
français un bulletin hebdomadaire qui
sera animée par notre ancien stagiaire
sophie claude miller félicitations
sophie claude et est-ce que escape
etienne est un modèle pour les
autochtones
est-ce que et pitié n'est plus attirant
pour les autochtones que radio canada
par exemple j'ai l'impression bas et
peut-être dans les communautés
anglophones qui tiennent et plus connu
comme un service de nouvelles parce que
en fait avancé n'y avait pas de
nouvelles en français ça va commencer
dans mon au québec sur sur le web et
fille tia n'est pas est pas perçue comme
un service de nouvelles encore mais ça
reste fortement changé parce que s'ils
font des produits beaucoup d'émissions
de divertissement et où il visite
beaucoup les communautés donc ghislaine
est très connu dans les communautés mais
est pas perçue comme elles savent où ils
veulent encore mais de changer non donc
le fait qu'un bulletin nouvelle soit
bientôt produits en français est ce que
ce serait finalement un plus et ça va
aider à la relève journalistique mais je
pense que oui je pense que c'est une
évidence parce qu'en plus ces faits dans
un contexte autochtone avec des
autochtones
ça va peut-être plus facile pour les
gens de s'y associer
oui au départ et on verra après jusqu'où
ils peuvent aller mais je pense que ça
peut être intéressant il faut que les
médias que ce soit et piquionne radio
canada moi c'est la presse avait pas été
l'homme ne veut pas donner une charge
seraient passés ici aujourd'hui donc il
faudrait continuer à ouvrir leurs portes
on est rendu là continuez vos efforts
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe là les gens de plus
plus ils m'en parlent dans les
communautés et j'aimerais ça faire ça
ben oui qui attend un peu mais une vraie
saint jean de bach oui mais ok après on
en reparlera parce que je pense que
c'est un métier ils voient qu'ils
peuvent donner leur parole en faisant
des choses passées c'est très bien de
moi dire oui c'est ce que j'avais dit
non on revient ce qu'on disait en début
d'émission ça prend des modèles gabriel
[Rires]
oui c'est beaucoup de pression mais en
même temps oui
réjean région je vous entends vous
alliez ajouté non non je l'y aider
parce que ça c'est vrai que ça lui
rajoute de la pression en me disant oui
c'est un beau sacrifice m'écoutais je
pense qu'on a fait le tour de la
question dernière chance si vous voulez
parlez vous exprimer sur ce sujet là
parce qu'on va le conclure dans quelques
instants
ben moi je dis comme tous il faut
continuer il faut il faut redoubler
d'efforts il faut penser long terme il
faut penser que les résultats dont on
part dont on rêve on arrivait à long
terme
ça prend des étapes évidemment il faut
pour ça ils voient pas du jour au
lendemain il y aura pas de grand soit il
y aura une série d'efforts qui vont
donner les résultats
on en voit déjà quelques uns mais mais
c'est pas suffisant
j'ajouterai que le la le travail de
représentativité des autochtones dans
les médias c'est pas seulement le
travail des autochtones mais aussi de
nos collègues non autochtone donc à
histoires autochtones cetc des non
autochtones mais qui ont déjà une
sensibilité à ces gens dangereux mais je
crois que dans d'autres secteurs c'est
important aussi de d'accorder une
attention particulière aux questions
autochtones donc c'est vraiment c'est un
travail tous ensemble on fait quoi oui
jean-françois je reste au niveau
publicitaire
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire
c'est juste quelqu'un le recrutement là
pour cet automne ça se termine bientôt
ça continue une bonne partie de l'été la
copie pour commencer
luton par la porte est grande ouverte
alors encore oui
isabelle j'ai envie d'ajouter aussi la
relève à venir dans le domaine des
communications du journalisme c'est bien
de pouvoir dans les choses en tant
qu'autochtones de pouvoir sensibiliser
ça change les choses même si on ne voit
pas tout de suite on se rend compte que
juste notre vision notre traitement
d'une nouvelle va permettre de
sensibiliser de changer un peu les
mentalités et réjean dernier mouche
puisque vous serez bientôt le grand
directeur du travail
mais comme je disais tantôt et puis
comme les autres le disais c'est qu'il
faut il faut continuer à faire les
efforts et puis ne pas abandonner
ça va être ça va être peut-être ça
reprendre quelques années mais il faut
surtout montrer aux jeunes qui qui a de
l'avenir dans ce mythe si l'eau parce
que présentement il y en a pas il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'emplois disponibles pour
les autochtones dans des domaines y en a
quelques uns au canada voilà merci merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à
cette grande discussion
isabelle picard jean françois baudet
gabriel paul luc simard et réjean n'est
qu'aux ados à québec merci à tous et la
semaine prochaine donc je vous le disais
lundi 3 juin nous aurons cette émission
spéciale à 13h30 donc sur notre site et
sur facebook et le 7 juin
vous serez prête isabelle on va parler
des réactions à ce rapport final donc il
va être déposée lundi
nous en parlerons entre autres avec
olivier michel alors je vous attendais
merci et merci à vous d'avoir été là
encore une fois cette semaine si vous
avez envie de commenter de poser des
questions vous avez bien sûr sur notre
page facebook
vous pouvez le faire en messenger vous
pouvez le faire directement sur la page
et surtout posé nous ont aussi en fait
poser en et ça c'était du radier
commissaire michèle audette dans qui
sera notre invité lundi à cette émission
spéciale
à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]